and now last week tonight asks how is
this still a thing this week the Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue how is this
still a thing
Sports Illustrated the preferred
magazine of dads and a crappers since
1954 highlighting great moments in sport
from the miracle on ice to that one time
Vince Lombardi got punched in the balls
by the Green Bay Packers and every
February s eye releases its most popular
annual issue to a creepy chorus of
approval all right check it out Mike
jerrick
look at the screen yes you the swimsuit
issue is coming out next Tuesday
newsstands it is a great great magazine
yeah and it's even worse when the models
are in the studio will you be my
Valentine I definitely want the
chocolate but there's a little bit of a
waiting list thank you so much Darren's
wife any moment now the swimsuit edition
was created by editor Andre Legare in
1964 to boost sales between sports
seasons and it was a perfect expression
of the 60s a time of such rampant casual
sexism that it eventually gave birth to
the sexual harassment in the workplace
film but our society moved on the
swimsuit issue not only hung around it
became the magazine's key selling point
you get basketball football tennis done
oh and the famous swimsuit issue
revealing 1991 swimsuit issue and the
free sneaker phone the swimsuit issue
that's the icing on the cake oh and the
swimsuit issue is still moving copies it
sold more than 800,000 copies on
newsstands in 2013 reportedly more than
ten times on a regular issue of Sports
Illustrated sold which raises the
question why sure at one point it was
tantalizing to receive a once annual
printed magazine of scantily clad women
but do people not understand they could
now just type naked ladies
to the internet and see what Google
throws at them even si seems to know
it's losing relevance which may be why
every year like clockwork they provoke
an attention-grabbing controversy
whether it's using other country
citizens as props some are calling them
at best culturally insensitive
objectifying women with an actual object
Barbie yes Barbie is in the cover of the
swimsuit issue and as you can imagine
there is outrage or this year baiting
the media with this some are
questioning whether the cover is too
lewd is it too risque when the line goes
this far what's left the vagina but
vagina is what's left and one of these
years in an act of desperation si will
probably put one on the cover and until
that time it's left to the rest of us to
ask ourselves the Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Issue how is this still a thing
[Applause]
you